The future of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is in jeopardy with Jonathan Majors' guilty
verdict. So what's the MCU to do with Kang?
Jonathan Majors has been at the center
of the news cycle for some time now for
alarming reasons. Multiple allegations of abuse,
his public relations team cutting ties with him,
and news of him being dropped from various
projects have taken him from a Hollywood
rising star to someone who's virtually
untouchable. On December 18, the Marvel
actor was found guilty of harassment
and assault in the third degree. Now,
Disney has announced that Majors will no
longer star in the Marvel Cinematic Universe.
"We just crossed… the threshold."
No other background details have been
announced as of the making of this video,
but the Hollywood Reporter noted
that Marvel Studios will still
be moving forward with the upcoming
"Avengers: The Kang Dynasty" film.
In November 2023, Marvel veteran writer
Michael Waldron (who worked on two seasons
of "Loki" and "Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness") came aboard the film — suggesting
that a recast (and rethinking of the film's
plot) has been in the works for some time.
Majors made his debut as a Kang variant, known
as He Who Remains, on the Disney+ series "Loki."
He returned to the MCU in"Ant-Man and the Wasp:
Quantumania," portraying a more vicious version
of Kang that rules the Quantum Realm. In the
"Ant-Man" film's storyline, he plays several
other Kang variants, such as Rama-Tut and
Immortus. Naturally, many have already begun
to ask the big question, where does Marvel
Studios go from here with the Kang character?
Throughout the MCU's Phase Four and Phase
Five, fans have gotten well-acquainted with
the multiverse. Various forms of Kang have
been depicted as masters of the multiverse,
capable of traversing it, bending it
to their will, and working together to
take out anyone against them. This is why he
and his variants have been positioned as the
Thanos-level threats of the Multiverse Saga,
which encompasses Phases Four, Five, and Six.
Though the folks at Marvel Studios likely could
find a way to write Kang out of the franchise
in favor of another overarching villain, it
arguably wouldn't be the right move. Fans
know about the Jonathan Majors situation and
remember how hard Kang was publicly pushed as
the MCU's next big bad. All of that information
would loom large over an abruptly Kang-free MCU,
likely to the detriment of the franchise. Since
the character seems so essential to the MCU's
immediate future, it looks like there's
only one viable way forward: recast Kang.
On paper, recasting Kang might seem like
a bad idea. He's a major antagonist who
has shown his face multiple times in the
MCU. So how could Marvel Studios bring
the character back with a new actor? Well,
in terms of the current multiversal story,
it makes sense for Kang variants to have different
faces. For instance, just look at "Spider-Man:
No Way Home," where Tom Holland, Tobey Maguire,
and Andrew Garfield all played different versions
of Peter Parker. Some different Kangs even appear
in "Quantumania's" brief post-credits scene.
Yes, variants can have differing faces in the MCU,
but there's behind-the-scenes precedent too. Since
the earliest days of the MCU, actors have been
swapped out in favor of new ones. One of the most
notable examples being Don Cheadle taking over
for Terrence Howard as James "War Machine" Rhodes.
"Next time, baby."
"Look, it's me, I'm here, deal with it."
Then there's Mark Ruffalo becoming Hulk
following Edward Norton's departure,
and Kathryn Newton replacing Emma Fuhrmann
as Cassie Lang. Even Thanos went from Damion
Poitier to Josh Brolin, proving there's
no role too big to recast in the MCU.
Regardless, there are so many ways Marvel
Studios could handle the future of Kang the
Conqueror in the MCU. Given how meticulous Marvel
Studios head Kevin Feige is with everything else,
though, it stands to reason he and his team
already have a multiversal plan in the works.